mein name ist herzlich willkommen hier
heute meine sachen her und zu einem
video in dem wir uns lieben sekunden
rätsel lösen werden deswegen habe ich
natürlich auch wieder meine detektiv
brille vorbereitet und ja dann können
wir starten das hier ist das erste
rätsel die frage ist wer ist dümmer hier
ist eine person die kletterte bei 1
achtung hund steht und hier ist eine
frau mit ihrem kind auf einem
zebrastreifen nämlich würde eigentlich
sagen weil personen sind nicht dumm weil
er klettert raus aus dem garten wo der
hund ist und die stehen auf einem
zebrastreifen das heißt er sollte
eigentlich nichts passieren ich würde
dennoch sagen dass die rechten hier
dünner sind weil er kettet ja aus dem
garten raus ja ach so es geht weiter
hier mit wärst du mal wieder hier eine
person die auf eine bank bis oder hier
jemand der an eine wand etwas dran
sprüht und im hintergrund steht ein
polizeiauto
ich habe absolut keine ahnung ich müsste
jetzt wirklich raten und dann würde ich
sagen der rechte weil er dem hintergrund
ein polizeiwagen steht aber ich habe
absolut keine ahnung und die website
sagt auch der rechte ich will zwar wird
das man nie gründe bekommt das hier ist
das nächste rätsel wären wir links
jemanden der am handy ist und im
hintergrund er trinkt gerade eventuell
seinen sohn keine ahnung wer und rechts
löscht jemand einen baum und im
hintergrund brennt das ganze haus
ich würde sagen der rechtssysteme also
die höhe da ist auf jeden fall gemacht
dafür dass da dass man eigentlich nicht
er trinkt von daher kommen tag
allerdings direkt weiter mit der
nächsten kategorie und zwar wo ist der
körper ich habe keine ahnung was hier
die frage ist bzw was man suchen soll
hier sind zwei leute die mit ihren
hunden gassi gehen der links hat einen
hund der rechts hat drei hunde was vom
körper ach so das ist ein suchspiel aber
gut dass hier ist auf jeden fall die
nächste situation wenn man den körper
finden muss eben hier sind ganz viele
leute in einem riesenrad und ja hier
oder oder wenig dumm das kommt natürlich
auch sagt also bisher finde ich dieses
komplette chris noch nicht so
anspruchsvoll aber es ist ja immer so
dass es zu beginn einfach wird uns zum
ende hin dann schwieriger hier steht
auch wieder man sollte einfach in die
kommentare schreiben also keine ahnung
was das soll ein dass das nächste rätsel
wer ist immer hier ist eine frau die
lippenstift benutzt und eine die auf dem
beifahrersitz etwas ist ich würde sagen
dass die linke person böhmer ist weil
sie ist ja lediglich beifahrerin als
beifahrerin kann sie natürlich einfach
was essen oder keine ahnung was machen
einem so die gabel wird in ihre kehle
sprechen wenn sie bremst auf jeden fall
die logik also keine ahnung was das sie
dafür eine erklärung ist aber machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten wärst du immer
rätsel hier links ist eine person auf
einem auf einem sorry muss mal ganz kurz
pausieren links ist eine person die
komplett normal motorrad fährt und
rechts person wie hinten drauf sitzt
hält dem fahrer die augen zu aber ich
sehe es schon kommen dass safe safety
linke personen irgendeiner form dünner
als ich appelliere dennoch an den
menschenverstand und sage dass die
rechten erläutert immer sind natürliche
riskiert das gleichgewicht zu verlieren
was für gleichgewichtiger der kaki noch
mal nicht sehen das hat nichts mit
gleichgewicht zu tun keine ahnung was
das rätsel schon wieder sollte er mich
jetzt auch wieder wer ist immer und zwar
eine person die sich selbst im handy
anschaut oder eine person die kaffee
trinkt und dabei herum fertig würde
sagen die rechte personen weil es
bestimmt irgendwas hier mit dem wasser
zu tun hat kommentare dieses verdammte
die letzten rätsel die ich hier auf
meinem kanal hochgeladen habe von wegen
wer steht zuerst im blabla die waren
auch alle von diesem kanal deswegen
dachte ich hague mit diesem video kann
man ja eigentlich nichts falsch machen
aber ich muss hier wirklich meine brille
abnehmen und sagen warum machst du ein
rätsel und sagst nicht die lösung das
ganze hat ja eventuell noch den vorteil
dass ich einfach euren lösungsidee in
die kommentare schreiben könnte
allerdings würde ich sagen mach mal
weiter ein bekannter kopf her linguine
wurde erstochen ok kraft die polizei
verdächtigt drei angestellte des
restaurants findest du den beweis und
kannst den mörder identifizieren also
wir haben hier eine person die vom
kühlschrank steht
wir haben hier eine person die gerade
kocht und hier eine person die mit einem
messer hantiert also ich würde sagen
diese personen die ein messer in der
hand hat
nee nee es ist der hier weil im
mülleimer liegen handschuhe und er hat
keine handschuhe an
okay er zoomt auf jeden fall auf den
müll einmal ran man sieht hier die
handschuhe die sind blutverschmiert und
diese person und diese person haben doch
ihre hand schon er hat keine handschuhe
allerdings so viel spaß gemacht hat man
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten wer ist
dümmer rätsel
hier ist eine person die sitzt auf dem
balkon fenster oder auf dem fensterrand
und er hängt von einem hochhaus einem
ich würde sagen der rechte ist dümmer
weil er einfach viel höher hängt das ist
das ist die begründung zu hoch wirklich
also ich weiß ich hab ich das ganze zu
kritisch sehe zu ernst nehme ich meine
es ist ja alles cool animiert und es
sind ja auch eigentlich ganz
interessante rätsel aber die begründung
zu hoch ist schon ein bisschen komisch
dass sie jetzt direkt das nächste wer
ist der ec ist eine person auf einem
kran der kran hält hier ein großes
gewicht und hier rechts ist eine person
auf einem auf einer eisenbahn wie auch
immer er hinkommt und die fährt
allerdings in einen tunnel von da will
ich sagen er kann einfach über den
tunnel drüber laufen und die linke
personen ist der kann nicht springen
er springt auf den kanada 6 er wirklich
vorne oder hinten nicht aber vielleicht
bin ich einfach zu blöd das ist auf
jeden fall das nächste rätsel hier ist
eine person die raucht und ist dabei ein
gepennt und direkt ist eine person die
raucht an einer tankstelle und man die
doch schon hier vorne ist benzin
also ich würde sagen safe die rechte
person musste man allerdings nun direkt
weiter mit einem vernünftigen rätsel
hier janine und rené gehen in ein
berühmtes steakhouse um zu abend zu
essen also janine und rené gehen heute
schön aus sie freuen sich auf einen
schönen armen mit guten fleisch und wein
doch von beginn an geht alles schief
so wie ich das video bisher
kennengelernt habe ist die frage
wahrscheinlich warum dreht sich die erde
im kreis es wird vermutlich wieder
absolut gar nichts mit dem rätsel zu tun
haben aber gut was geht dann alles
schief sagt nicht an ihn wird jetzt
ermordet
jeannin und remy werden nur zeuge eines
verbrechens einem jemand hat auf der
toilette
der kellner umgebracht fünf minuten
später ist die polizei im restaurant
also hier ist der polizist hier sind die
leute im restaurant die beamten verhören
die belegschaft ich habe in der küche
das fleisch gegrillt sagt die eine
person die nächste person sagt ich war
auch in der küche also er hat bisher
kein so gutes alibi
ich habe den fisch für das schicke
waschen okay das hat sich schon deutlich
besser an ich habe in der küche salat
gemacht sagt die person auf der linken
seite die dame mit den roten haaren sagt
ich habe kartoffeln und zwiebeln
geschält ok und er sagt ich habe an der
bar die weingläser poliert alles klar
wer ist der oder die mörderin also er
hat angeblich das fleisch vorbereitet er
hier vorne hat den fisch gewaschen für
das sushi sie hier vorne hat irgendwie
kartoffeln und zwiebeln geschält oder
irgendwie so was er hier vorne hat salat
gemacht und er hat weingläser poliert
ich habe absolut keine ahnung ich würde
jetzt einfach mal raten und sagen dass
es diese person ist mit den weingläsern
wer serviert sushi in einem steak
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist das zweite rätsel was wirklich
sinn ergibt machen wir allerdings weiter
mit einem wer ist dümmer rätsel mal
wieder hier ist eine person die scherben
von einer pipette zusammen legt und der
rechts trinkt whisky trinkt erst medizin
und trinkt dann nach alkohol
ich würde sagen die rechte person weil
hier war ja nichts drin also ich sage
dir echte person ist dümmer und die
person ist auch immer tabletten
einnehmen mit alkohol ja das sollte man
wirklich nicht machen das kann zu
schwerer vergiftungen führen
das vorletzte wer ist über rätsel eine
person die mit ihrem sohn über eine
vielbefahrene straße läuft nun mitten
auf der straße steht oder jemand der mit
seinem sohn der letzten person offenbar
gekommen
die sind beide dumm
links ist immer ja ich weiß nicht warum
aber werden keine zeit haben zum bremsen
macht hat letzte rätseln lassen wie
danach in ruhe mit diesem quiz wer ist
immer eine person die in der badewanne
sitzt und sich fühlt oder auf der
rechten seite eine person die in der
badewanne sitzt und ihr handy benutzt
okay das finde ich selber sehr
interessantem ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht warum man in der badewanne sitzt
und sich föhnt beim das macht wirklich
vorn und hinten keinen sinn also rechts
wird auf jeden fall noch mehr sinn
machen finde ich mit dem handy
das ding ist allerdings ich glaube dass
rechts zimmer ist weil die steckdose
direkt über der badewanne ist und hier
ich glaube föhn ist isoliert das kabel
ich habe aber keine ahnung also ich
würde sagen dass die rechte personen
definitiv dümmer ist und es ist wirklich
die rechte person
wer würde es dort anbringen nicht klug
ja wirklich dankeschön für dieses
wundervolle rätsel video an der stelle
wird das heutige wieder ist allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde es tut
mir leid auf das heutige rätsel wie die
als nicht so krass war aber ich kann mir
die videos nicht vorher angucken weil
sonst würde ich ja schon die lösung
wissen ich glaube es war eigentlich ganz
cool von den animationen von den rätseln
an sich aber die begründungen und
lösungen werden sie denn überhaupt mal
vorhanden waren
das wirkt er halt alles irgendwie nicht
so durchdacht aber gut schreibt mir auf
jeden fall nach unten die kommentare
welche lösungen ihr bei den sachen wo
kommentare stand genommen hätte und
leute falls sie noch kein abonnent von
meinem kanal klickt auf abonnieren das
kostenlose passt keine videos mehr und
ich sehe halt immer das voll viele also
wirklich 80 prozent schauen meine videos
an dabei sind nicht abonnent hey warum
die von ihm einen kanal los
[Musik]